temps court les marchés de noël c'est du
tourisme du folklore de la sécurité mais
aussi de l'emploi car les secteurs du
commerce de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration recrute encore ainsi 17
entreprises se sont réunis ici au
conseil départemental du haut rhin à
colmar pour la sixième édition du
christmas jobs une matinée sous les
employeurs ont rencontré des demandeurs
d'emploi dont des bénéficiaires du rsa
préparé au préalable par pôle emploi les
candidats étaient plus de 150 à s'être
présentés il avait entre cinq et sept
minutes pour convaincre les recruteurs
45 postes sont à pourvoir
on écoute tout de suite la présidente du
conseil départemental du haut-rhin
brigitte klinkert le directeur de l'
agence pôle emploi françois picard au
micro de gilles kuntz rien que sur le
marché de noël de colmar
il ya des centaines de milliers voire
millions de touristes qui viennent et
donc les commerçants ont besoin d'avoir
des effectifs beaucoup plus important
que le reste de l'année et donc on a
besoin de salariés et c'est une belle
occasion pour les bénéficiaires du rsa
est bien de retrouver la possibilité de
mettre le pied à l'étrier et d'avoir
pendant quelques semaines un emploi
l'intérêt de ces offres d'emploi qui
sont dans un premier temps saisonniers
pour la fin d'année c'est que forcément
elles vont permettre de pérenniser
certains postes si les candidats donnent
satisfaction